DAN ALBERT: So mostly
just a quick update
on what the NDK has gone
through in the last year
and a little bit forward
looking stuff, as well as
a tiny bit of advice on the
64-bit transition that's
coming up.
That's me, Dan Albert.
That's where we have our
bug tracker and some wiki
and some announcements
and stuff.
So in the last year,
we've done r15 and r16.
r15 is when we switched over
to the new form of the headers,
which has the one single
blob of headers that
are correct for every
API level, instead
of having a bunch of bug
fixes only in the newest one,
and the old ones are
just horribly out of date
and broken.
r16, that became a requirement,
and we fixed up libc++
and libandroid support.
If you were here last year,
or have me talk before,
you'll know that libc++
was really in a beta state
in the NDK, because of this
libandroid support that we used
to back port APIs to back
then, as early as gingerbread.
We've cleaned all that up,
so this is now actually
the STL we recommend.
In r17, it's
actually the default.
We removed support for ARM5
and the MIPS flavors, which
is probably a welcome
change for all of you,
because that's less stuff
that you have to test.
r17 is in beta right now.
In theory, stable's
going out tomorrow,
but I haven't spoken to QA
yet today, so we'll see.
Defaults to libc++, it
adds the O-MR1 APIs.
It adds the P APIs.
More of those landing tomorrow.
Asan no longer requires
root, which is fantastic.
You now just have to ship the
shared library in your app,
and you use this wrap.sh,
which is an O feature,
to make sure it gets
loaded in your APK.
LTO now works on Windows.
I know that was a huge thing
for game developers, so hooray.
And apparently, we
removed those ABIs again.
I think that was r17, and
they were deprecated in r16.
r18, we've been
working on for a while.
It includes clang-tidy
support, and it also
removes all the
old crap that we've
been working on deprecating
for the last few years--
so GCC, the other STLs.
Starting with r18, it is
clang, and it is libc++,
and that is it.
Far fewer combinations
to test, so everything
should be much higher quality.
And it should be less
complications of getting
all your middleware to match.
r19, this is going to be
a big change for anyone
in the room that maintains
their own build system,
but it should be the
change that you get
to delete a ton of your code.
All of the tool
chains are just going
to be standalone tool chains.
Android will start working
like a normal cross-compiler,
where you're just
call clang, you say,
I'm targeting error 6426, and
it just does the right thing.
You no longer have to know all
the crazy flags and the paths
to everything.
Yeah, clang transition
is complete.
We are done with
this inside Google.
All of userspace was clang
in Marsh-- well, most--
in Marshmallow, all
of it in Nougat,
most-- some of the
kernels in Oreo.
It's now-- it was the
default compiler starting
in NDK r13, which is
a year and a half ago.
It is the only one
in the next release.
It's probably less exciting
for this room, but new APIs
and stuff for libc.
The clang fortified source
is a security measure
that maybe people in
this room care about.
It'll do things like
check buffer overruns
at both compile time and
some mitigation at runtime.
Again, P, more APIs.
CPU profiling, we ship
simpleperf in the NDK.
It has, for ages, had a
command-line interface,
but in Studio 3.1, it's got
a UI, which looks like that.
The command-line tool
itself can spit out
these flame graphs, which
are really cool, helpful
for drilling down into what
exactly is going wrong.
Updates on command-line
tools to O/P. Got
a whole bunch of new
things in toybox, adb
has been sped up on USB3.
And like I said, advice
on the 64-bit transition.
We're not trying to
create fire drills here.
It's really for the users.
They only have to
run one zygote if you
have a 64-bit-only device.
If there are any reasons
why you can't hit the 2019
deadline on that, let us know.
We do want to know about
that, and we'll work with you
to try to sort that out.
The 64-bit transition does
come with some performance
improvements.
If Tim is still in
the room, he can maybe
hint at what they are,
because I don't know numbers.
TIM: 5% to 10%.
DAN ALBERT: 5% to 10%.
OK, that was my guess.
And that will vary based on
your application, obviously.
Having the higher
minimum minSdkVersion.
Since 64-bit only came in L,
you can't target anything lower
than L, which means you
have newer APIs available.
You don't need
libandroid support.
And we are working with
all the engine companies
to make sure that their
engines are 64-bit ready
by the time this happens.
You know who you are.
And for the actual how to
port your code to 64-bit,
we found these
three really helpful
when we were porting
the platform.
It'll catch the cases
where, oops, you
were using an int
instead of a pointer,
or, oops, you're using a
pointer instead of an int.
Implicit function
declaration is a fun one,
because C, in all of
its wisdom, decided
that a function
that was not defined
had the return type of int,
which is very frustrating when
it actually returns a pointer.
Because it will just truncate
it, and your code will explode.